اشهد جامعتك واستغرب السعوديه تدجينا مقر
المركز الاقليمي للتغير المناخي حيث يهدف
المركز الى تعزيز الاداب البيئي في
السعوديه وان يكون مرجعا مهما في الحفاظ
على البيئه واستدامتها كما من المتوقع
ايضا ان يكون المركز الرئيس لتوفير
المعلومات والتحديات من العواصف لمناطق
البلاد ودول الخليج
من جده ينضم الينا البروفيسور ياسر ابو
نجنائب رئيس مركز التغير المناخي بروفيسور
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
بدايه نريد ان نعرف اكثر عن هذا المركز
ابرز ما يملكه من معلومات
لكي يدعم ايضا المعلومات المناخيه خصوصا
نعم تغيرات المناخيه المتسارعه التي
يشهدها العالم وتشهدها المنطقه تحديدا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم اجمعين شكرا اخويا
نايف تحت الفرصه هذه الحقيقه اليوم تم
تدشين مركز التغير المناخي في جامعه الملك
عبد الله بحضور معالي وزير البيئه المهندس
عبد الرحمن الفضلي وبحضور الدكتور ايمن
غلام رئيس مركز الارصاد الوطني وهو الداعم
الرئيسي لمركز التغيير المناخي الذي انشئ
في جامعه الملك عبد الله
المركز هذا انشئ بعد ما اعلنوا سمو سيدي
الامير محمد بن سلمان في المبادره الخضراء
بانشاء هذا المركز الذي سوف يخدم المملكه
والدول المجاوره في المستقبل
المركز هو سوف يكون
حجر زاويه اللي داخل المملكه في تقديم
الادوات والمعلومات والتحاليل المناخيه
التي سوف تساعد صناع القرار في المملكه
لاتخاذ القرارات المهمه والاستراتيجيه كما
كما يقوم المركز بوضع الخطط المستقبليه
لعمل استدامه دائمه لحفاظ على
التغيرات اللي بتصير في داخل المملكه
بالنسبه للمناخ هذا بصوره مبسطه اخويا
نايف وش ابرز الخطط والبرامج اللي انتم
حتعملوا عليها بروفيسور يعني سواء على
المستوى الاقليمي على المستوى الدولي
تعاونكم ايضا مع الدول الاخرى هل هو في
امداد معلومات لهذه الدول ام تبادل
الخبرات والمعلومات ايضا حتى كذلك بينهم
وبين بينكم وبين هذه الدول
احنا الحقيقه في في المركز الخطط اللي
موضوعه انه احنا فاتحين باب التعاون اول
ما بدانا عملنا ورشات عمل وعملنا مؤتمرات
هنا داخل المملكه مع مع
الجهات الحكوميه والخاصه وسعيناهم لتبادل
الخبرات والبيانات معهم
كذلك وضعنا تقريبا قبل شهر مؤتمر مع الدول
العربيه وشرحنا لهم عن المركز واهداف
المركز وخططه المستقبليه
وطلبنا منهم التعاون والتبادل الخبرات
واحنا حنكون في هذا المجال من القاده
الرئيسيين في هذا المجال طب احنا دكتور
ايضا نطلب منك انه احنا نريد رؤيه هذا
المركز ونحرك الكاميرا ايضا نشوف وش موجود
في هذا المركز اذا سمحت تطلب من المصور
ايضا وتشرح لنا بشكل المركز المركز
المركز الحقيقي احنا في جامعه الملك عبد
الله عندنا الحاسوب الخارق شاهين واحنا في
المركز هذا بنستخدم عده نماذج عدديه زي ما
انت شايف امامك هذا اللي هي
النموذج عددي
لحركه التيارات الهوائيه وحركه
التيارات المائيه للبحر الاحمر كما ممكن
اوريك هنا عندنا هنا في الشاشه التي
امامنا امامنا هذا احد النماذج العدديه
الذي يستخدم في الجامعه فاذا احنا اخذنا
مثلا
الرياح نجد استخدام الرياح هنا موجوده في
في
على الشاشه زي ما انت شايفها لو اخذنا
مثلا
لموضوع الامواج في البحر الاحمر او اذا
اخذنا موضوع
زي ما هو واضح امامك كذلك موضوع التيارات
كثيره بصراحه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه الجمله وعلى
وجودك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض جدا
ضم البروفيسور ياسر ابو نجا نائب رئيس
مركز التغير المناخي شكرا